ah better protect your bubble calm proud
sponsors of swype on Sky News you're
watching swype coming up on the show
this week bringing the stadium to
digital life how Wembley is changing
with the time the little device aim to
take a big bite out of home Wi-Fi black
spot and no zombies this week but
prepare for a voyage in a submerged
Victorian London in our games review
hello and welcome to swipe this week
we're at one of the world's most
recognizable sports venues you don't
need me to tell you that that is Wembley
Stadium and as well as football rugby
NFL and major music events are all
staged here it's nearly a hundred years
old but at the moment is undergoing a
major digital upgrade it's a shame we
couldn't upgrade the weather to his
Russell later this year Wembley is
planning to start using its arch to
display social sentiment during events
one of many innovations being brought to
the National Stadium so just imagine
you're in your seat at the big match and
you can turn the arch your teams colors
simply by tweeting red green or blue and
the lights in the art will also react to
significant moments like goals & crowd
noise and reflect who's winning more
than 2 million spectators came here in
2014 and apps will allow them to use
their smartphones for everything from
entering the stadium to ordering and
paying for food and getting a message on
to the big screens the use of technology
can really be a great benefit in
speeding or processes and making finding
your way under steady much more positive
I think there's a gimmick the element or
this element about the art just looks
something that I'll be taking part in so
whether you're here for football rugby
NFL or music the new features will
undoubtedly make it more memorable and
save time but will they add to or
detract from the actual event well
players point of view you know you know
exactly what you got to do when your net
pitch
go out there perform you've been
training all week to make sure you can
perform so whatever goes on halftime or
before the game or during the game you
have to just concentrate on your game
Wembley is not alone in turning digital
the levi's stadium in San Francisco home
of the 49ers NFL team is billed as the
world's most high-tech boasting as it
does fully 1,000 Wi-Fi access points can
Wembley compete with that type of
connectivity everybody reaches for their
phone at the same time when a half half
time whistle goes so we've engineered
the stadium capacity to be able to
guarantee reliability even up at those
moments of highest peak up to ninety
nine point nine five percent that's for
voice calling or for even making a data
connection the Wembley experience is
changing dramatically thanks to
technology with the arch playing its
part and apps are also making a big
difference as Gemma found out earlier
that she made her way here so here we
are we've arrived at Wembley Park tube
station on our journey to the stadium
today and we're going to use a couple of
new apps so yeah the first one is the
cash on tap but I can use to travel on
London Underground oh we can sigh
through with this thank you very much so
here we are Brunswick stadium new
digital screens in place and it gray and
we're using these to engage our fans to
entertain our fans say they can place
their thoughts ok freakin sweet I want
to know and pictures what about a selfie
a selfie mr. something out we love a
good selfie on swype let's do a selfie
now ready ready oh there we are
fantastic but I've always wondered when
posting two big screens like that how do
you vet them how do you stop people
putting up Mooney so my team sitting
Embley have them access to everything
that's actually tweeted or posted they
moderate sit
let's go into the stadium have a look at
what else we ha there we are even bigger
we're still out there yes it just as
well you've got your team vetting for
those healthy people absolutely believe
it the final thing to have a look at
today is sharing your thoughts on
Wembley through the app with a big
message to our video boards oh is it so
I'm gonna write something here just like
sending a treat our little pier on the
massive screen just like our selfie
indeed ok what should we put I love
Wimbley I love Wembley naturally so
let's have a look I heard there it is I
love Wembley hi Gemma how do you choose
which messages to post up there
something that that everybody can
actually relate to i think is key but
not everything gets up there clearly oh
and what a shame there aren't 89,000
other fans here to see what I love
Wembley message you'll have to come back
to me you're watching swype still to
come sandals swords and urns in ancient
Greece that's in our game
but first here's a roundup of some of
this week's other tech news Twitter's
revenues nearly doubled in the final
three months of last year it took four
hundred and seventy nine million dollars
more than 310 million pounds despite
losing money overall in 2014 also this
week Twitter's chief executive said in a
leaked memo that he's ashamed of how
poorly the company has dealt with trolls
get ready for the next big launch from
Samsung the company has sent out
invitations to its event at the Mobile
World Congress trade show in Barcelona
next month where it'll be announcing its
new flagship galaxy phone an adware
virus has been affecting Android devices
via some apps in the Google Play Store
it causes the browser to open constantly
with adverts appearing to there have
already been 5 to 10 million downloads
on one of the infected apps a new device
is making bad home Wi-Fi a thing of the
past the ero improves connection by
abolishing dead zones where your signal
is weaker the company says it only takes
three devices to cover a typical home
now there's no football in our games
review this week but we do have plenty
of ancient Greek mythology of course
it's Martin Robinson they start with a
legend of zelda majora's mask there's
lots of debate whether Majora's Mask is
the greatest Zelda game ever made but
one thing you can say for sure is it's
the strangest Majora's Mask was
interesting it was made in a year it was
quite a short turnaround but in that
year Nintendo managed to make a game
which is absolutely crazy there's been
nothing like that since it's got a weird
time teller mechanic whereby you have
three days to basically solve the task
at hand and that kind of loops over
Groundhog Day esque and you kind of live
those three days over again again it
makes a really interesting game mechanic
and one that's really well suited to
portable play as well
I pothi on apologies if I mispronounced
that I think that's right first and most
importantly it's a free game on ps4 if
you've got PlayStation Plus but beyond
just being free it's also really
interesting really gorgeous
side-scrolling combat game in a vein of
things like Castlevania or Metroid and
the one of the things you'll notice is
it's an absolutely gorgeous game it
looks like you're playing and some Greek
art like you're playing across the side
of some ancient requires beyond the
actual look at the game itself it's
really interesting game kind of a mix of
exploration and combat and yeah it's
well worth checking out even more so
given the fact that it's free and
pleasurable Sun the sea is a super
interesting game on PC which is just
come out of a access or it's been since
July last year it could well be one of
the most interesting games are going to
see this year we're going to be talking
about it a lot longer I would be
surprised if it ends up in some games of
the year list to come into 2015 as well
this has a bit more exploration in it
you're in a boat charting their indices
it's absolutely gorgeous the world
you're exploring is really dense and
well-written it's a game we're going to
talking about and playing from long long
tentacle oh it's a lot warmer down here
isn't it that's because this is the
England players dressing room we're
actually inside it take a look around so
for now I'll say goodbye thanks for
joining us and you can keep up to date
with all latest tech stories on sky
knees the ipad our smartphone our skies
calm and our youtube channel but for now
bye bye
gotcha ah better protect your bubble
calm proud sponsors of swype on Sky News